Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Nothing seems more calculated to put a smile on the face of a nation than a tremendous haul of Olympic medals. As we are recording this episode of The Rest Is History on the modern Olympics, Britain is rejoicing at the news that we have podiumed in a range of sports, swimming, diving, cross-country mountain biking. And perhaps by the time you listen to this, there will be even more.
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。没有什么比赢得海量的奥运奖牌更能让一个国家的民众脸上露出笑容了。正当我们录制这期关于现代奥运会的《The Rest Is History》节目时，英国正为我们在游泳、跳水、越野山地自行车等一系列项目中登上领奖台的消息而欢欣鼓舞。也许等你听到这期节目时，还会有更多奖牌入账。
And of course, this, for anyone who lived through it, cannot help but remind us of nine years ago and the wonderful two weeks at London 2012, when the enthusiasm of journalists and columnists went off the scale and it's mentioned in a wonderful book I've been reading The Games a Global History of the Olympics by David Goldblatt and he's looking at the press coverage and he cites a columnist who was writing in the Daily Mail who stands proxy, David Goldblatt writes, albeit at the more florid end of the past two weeks have been a patriotic extravaganza with few parallels in our recent history. And I think that regular listeners to the rest of history will know who David Goldblatt is talking about here, who this columnist for the Daily Mail
当然，对于任何经历过那个时期的人来说，这都不由得让人想起九年前伦敦2012年奥运会那美妙的两周。当时记者和专栏作家的热情达到了无以复加的地步，大卫·戈德布拉特（David Goldblatt）在我一直在读的一本精彩著作《奥运会：一部全球史》（The Games a Global History of the Olympics）中提到了这一点。他研究了当时的媒体报道，并引用了一位《每日邮报》专栏作家的文章。大卫·戈德布拉特写道，这名作家代表了过去两周里那种狂热的爱国主义狂欢，在我们的近代史上难有匹敌。我想，《The Rest Is History》的忠实听众会知道大卫·戈德布拉特在这里说的是谁，这位《每日邮报》的专栏作家
might be, Dominic Sandbrook. So I thought that was going to be embarrassing, but then you used the word podiumed, and I realised that actually I've come out of that much better than I thought. I'm obsessed by verbing. I think it was 2012, wasn't it, that it all kicked off and people talked about meddling and meddling. I cannot stop doing it. Anyway, so I'm guessing from that, you know,
可能是谁呢，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）。所以，我本以为那会很尴尬，但接着你用了“podiumed”（登上领奖台）这个词，我意识到其实我的表现比想象的好得多。我对动词化（verbing）着迷。我想那是2012年吧，这一切开始盛行，人们开始谈论“meddling”（争夺奖牌，由medal动词化）之类的词。我简直停不下来。总之，我从你的话中猜测，
you're at the more florid end of the enthusiasm for Olympic mania, that you're a big fan. No, that was a good example. About a week before the Olympics began, I'd written a column saying I hated the Olympics and it was all going to be a disaster. And in traditional columnist fashion, you know, 10 days later I was miraculously converted to the choice of the Olympics.
你是奥运狂热中表现得比较狂热的那一端，你是它的超级粉丝。不，那是个很好的例子。在奥运会开幕前大约一周，我曾写过一篇专栏文章，说我讨厌奥运会，这一切都将是一场灾难。按照传统专栏作家的风格，你知道的，10天后我又奇迹般地转变成为了奥运会的拥趸。
Actually, I'm quite an Olympic sceptic. I genuinely wouldn't be bothered if the Olympics were abandoned. And of course, I celebrate British medals as much as anybody. But I think as we will discover the history of the olympics i mean we did the history of the ancient olympics last time and that was a pretty gory business the history of the modern olympics is is also a pretty gory business i think though in a different way brilliant but but but from the historian's point of view they're brilliant aren't they because they're a kind of four yearly temperature check absolutely yeah state of culture global politics whatever yeah which just makes
实际上，我是一个坚定的奥运会怀疑论者。如果奥运会被取消，我真的会无所谓。当然，我会和任何人一样庆祝英国获得奖牌。但正如我们将要发现的奥运会历史——我的意思是，我们上次做了古代奥运会的历史，那是一段相当血腥的历史——现代奥运会的历史也是一段相当血腥的历史，我认为只是方式不同而已。太棒了，但是从历史学家的角度来看，它们太棒了，不是吗？因为它们是对文化状态、全球政治等等的一种四年一度的体温检测，
them fantastic I mean and until I read David Goldblatt's book which I didn't really know much about the uh the olympics the modern olympics but it's such a fascinating topic and actually I kind of fell down any number of rabbit holes looking at the beginnings of the olympics yeah and actually if you go through it they are they are so interesting they are the stories around them so peculiar but but dominic you you um when we talk about the you know the absolute beginnings of the modern olympics yes i mean this is very much your patch isn't it because basically um it's it's a kind of cotswold shropshire story it is it is so the very first well this we'll get to shropshire in a minute because because I think Shropshire is where the Olympics really began, the modern Olympics. But there's an antecedent, which is, of course, the Cotswold Olympics, which I'm sure you know about, set up by a man called Robert Dover in 1612 in Chipping Camden.
这绝对是……是的。这让它们变得妙不可言。我的意思是，在读大卫·戈德布拉特的书之前，我其实对奥运会——现代奥运会——知之甚少，但这真是一个引人入胜的话题。事实上，我在研究奥运会的起源时，掉进了数不清的“兔子洞”（知识盲区）里。是的，事实上，如果你深入了解，它们是如此有趣，它们周围的故事是如此奇特。但是多米尼克，你……当我们谈论现代奥运会的绝对起源时，是的，这非常符合你的研究领域，对吧？因为基本上……这是一个科茨沃尔德-什罗普山（Cotswold-Shropshire）的故事。确实是，确实是。所以第一个——好吧，我们一会儿会讲到什罗普山，因为我认为什罗普山才是奥运会真正开始的地方，即现代奥运会。但有一个前身，当然就是科茨沃尔德奥运会（Cotswold Olympics），我确信你对此有所了解，它由一个名叫罗伯特·多弗（Robert Dover）的人于1612年在奇平坎普顿（Chipping Campden）创立。
And basically the most, you know, the Hollywood sort of quintessence of Englishness, isn't it? Chipping Camden, sort of arts and crafts, movement, bucolic, pastoral idyll. And he set it up. It's unclear why he set it up. Some people think it's to do with the defence of the realm and manly virtues. And others say it's about something at a time of great uncertainty and sort of political unrest.
基本上是最……你知道的，好莱坞式的英国性之精髓，不是吗？奇平坎普顿，某种工艺美术运动、田园诗般的风光。是他创立的。目前还不清楚他为什么要创立它。有些人认为是与保卫国家和男子气概有关。另一些人则说，这是在充满巨大不确定性和某种政治动荡时期发生的事。
Isn't it kind of also, he's Catholic? I think something like that, yes. Very Anglo-Catholic. So isn't it also about kind of Maypoles and Mary England? I think there is a lot of that, yes. A lot of kind of frolicking. Well, the sports. As the Puritans are gearing up to ban it.
难道不是因为他是个天主教徒吗？我想差不多是这样，是的。非常接近盎格鲁-天主教。所以难道不也与五月柱和“欢乐的英格兰”（Merry England）有关吗？我想这其中有很多这样的成分，是的。有许多类似于狂欢的活动。好吧，体育运动。正值清真寺……哦不，清教徒正准备将其取缔之际。
Exactly. The sports are very Mary England. Sledgehammer throwing, fighting with cudgels, shin kicking, which they still do and my favorite sport are you are you are you an aficionado of dweil flunking tom uh we talk a little else in the holland household so just of course i'm a great fan but just remind me what it is do you want me to remind you the rules i'll remind you the So a dull-witted person is chosen as the referee, or job-an-owl.
没错。这些体育运动非常具有“欢乐的英格兰”色彩。大锤投掷、棍棒搏击、踢小腿（他们现在仍然这样做）以及我最喜欢的运动。汤姆，你是……你是……你是“倒啤酒游戏”（dwyle flunking）的爱好者吗？我们在霍兰德家里很少谈及其他事，所以当然我是它的超级粉丝，但请提醒我一下这是怎么玩的。你想让我提醒你规则吗？我来提醒你。所以一个愚笨的人被选为裁判，被称为“job-an-owl”（猫头鹰工作者）。
The two teams decide who will flunk first by tossing a sugar beet. What is flunking? Well, I'm going to explain. The game begins when the job-an-owl shouts, here you go together. The non-flunking team join hands and dance in a circle around a member of the flonking team, a practice known as girting.
两支队伍通过抛甜菜来决定谁先“flunk”（挥舞或投掷）。什么是“flunk”？嗯，我会解释的。游戏开始时，裁判大喊：“开始吧！”不进行“flunk”的队伍手拉手，围绕着“flunk”队伍的一名成员跳圆圈舞，这种做法被称为“girting”。
The flonker dips his dweil-tipped driveler into a bucket of beer, then spins around in the opposite direction to the girters and flonks his dweil at them. If the dweil misses completely, it is known as a swodge. Well, naturally. What else would it be called? When this happens, the flunker must drink the contents...
挥舞者将蘸有“dweil”（抹布）的投掷器浸入一桶啤酒中，然后朝着与跳圆圈舞的人相反的方向旋转，并把抹布朝他们扔去。如果抹布完全没有击中，这就被称为“swodge”（空投）。嗯，理所当然。不然还能叫什么呢？当这种情况发生时，挥舞者必须喝下一……
of an ale... Sorry. Sorry. Control yourself. The fronker must drink the contents of an ale... of an ale-filled gazunder before the wet dweil has passed from hand to hand along the lines of now non-girting girders chanting the ceremonial mantra of pot pot pot so that's dweil flunking and i believe it was invented actually
一满杯啤酒……抱歉。抱歉。克制一下。挥舞者必须喝下一满杯啤酒……一个装满啤酒的痰盂（gazunder）里的啤酒，此时那块湿抹布已经顺着那些不再跳圆圈舞的人手递手传了下去，他们嘴里还要吟诵着仪式性的咒语：“pot pot pot”（罐罐罐）。这就是“dweil flunking”，据我所知，它实际上是发源于
in east anglia and has since moved to the cotswold olympics and the cotswold olympics um so why is that not on sky sport well this is the thing why don't they do that at the olympics i mean they do football and that's a complete joke at the o. They do basketball, which is also a joke. I like the idea that the ref has to be a village idiot. Yes, a dull-witted, jobber now, I think. Anyway. That would be great, wouldn't it? So they do these kind of...
东安格利亚（East Anglia），后来移到了科茨沃尔德奥运会上。那么，为什么这个没有在天空体育（Sky Sports）播出呢？这就是问题所在，为什么他们不在奥运会上做这个？我的意思是，他们有足球，这在奥运会上简直是个彻头彻尾的笑话。他们有篮球，这也是个笑话。我喜欢裁判必须是个村里傻子的这个设定。是的，我想是一个愚笨的、兼职的猫头鹰。无论如何。那不是很棒吗？所以他们搞了这些……
I mean, obviously, the Cotswold Olympics, which still continues, has now become a bit of a sort of... It's become a self-conscious kind of joke. But obviously, the interesting thing to me about this is that that's 1612. They didn't do the Dwarf Flunky in 1612, by the way. That's a more recent innovation. But obviously, there was a buried memory, wasn't there,
我的意思是，很明显，仍在继续的科茨沃尔德奥运会现在已经变成了一种……它变成了一种自我意识的笑话。但显然，对我来说有趣的是，那是1612年。顺便说一句，他们当时在1612年并没有玩“倒啤酒游戏”。那是一个较新的创新。但很明显，有一种埋藏的记忆，不是吗？
of the ancient Olympics. It gets recaptured with the Renaissance. Yeah, Hellenified. So Shakespeare starts to talk about kind of Olympian contests and so on. And Milton talks about Satan as being like an Olympian runner. Does he? Yeah, which of course
关于古代奥运会的记忆。它随着文艺复兴而重新焕发生机。是的，被希腊化了。因此，莎士比亚开始谈论诸如奥林匹克竞赛之类的事情，弥尔顿也将撒旦比作奥运会赛跑运动员。是吗？是的，当然
Milton is writing very much from the Puritan end of things, and so it's not surprising that with the Civil War and the Protectorate, that that gets banned, right? Yeah, exactly. There's a lot of distrust of sport because I suppose organised sport is seen as...
弥尔顿写作时非常带有清真寺……清教徒的立场，所以随着内战和护国公时期的到来，这种活动被禁掉也就不足为奇了，对吧？是的，完全如此。人们对体育运动有很多不信任，因为我想有组织体育运动被视为……
It's exactly what we were talking about before, isn't it? They are much closer to that sense of sport as religious, as part of a religious festival. But clearly they have absolutely no idea at all about what the ancient olympics actually involved and i guess that as you go through the 18th into the 9th century people do start to have a better sense of that so 1794 apparently there was a chariot race at newmarket between nanny hodges and lady lads for 500 guineas and the time said that it was something like a revival of the olympic games
这正是我们之前讨论过的，不是吗？它们更接近那种将体育视为宗教、视为宗教节日一部分的概念。但显然，他们对于古代奥运会实际上涉及的内容完全没有任何概念，我想随着18世纪进入19世纪，人们确实开始对这一点有了更好的理解——所以据记载，1794年在纽马克特（Newmarket）的娜尼·霍奇斯（Nanny Hodges）和拉兹夫人（Lady Lads）之间曾举行了一场价值500几尼（guineas）的战车赛，《泰晤士报》称这有点像是奥运会的复兴。
right that's interesting and didn't the french revolutionaries yeah danton yeah was a big fan big fan of them it was they used metric measures first time metric measures were used in sports shameful moment um so yes and then of course you've got g Greece. So when Greece becomes independent from the Ottomans. Yeah, 1821. There are kind of calls from poets and nationalists and so on to reinstate the Olympic Games. And they do have. They have, in 1859, they hold what are called Olympic Games for over three Sundays in Athens.
没错，这很有意思。法国大革命的领导人难道不也……是的，丹东（Danton）是个狂热粉丝。他们是奥运会的超级粉丝。那是他们首次在体育运动中使用公制单位，这是一个耻辱的时刻……所以是的，然后当然你有了希腊。因此，当希腊从奥斯曼帝国独立出来时——是的，1821年——诗人、民族主义者等各方纷纷呼吁恢复奥运会。他们确实这样做了。1859年，他们在雅典举行了历时三个礼拜日的所谓奥运会。
And they have running, they have horse and chariot races, they have discus, javelin, and they have the climbing of a greasy pole. So Benjamin Disraeli could participate in that and would do very well. I mean, he'd have been there, perfect timing for him.
在那里他们有赛跑、赛马和战车赛、铁饼、标枪，还有爬油滑的杆子。因此，本杰明·迪斯雷利（Benjamin Disraeli）可以参与其中，并且会表现得非常好。我的意思是，他当时会在那里，这对他来说是完美的时机。
So those games, they have prize money donated from a small town in the midlands of england called much when lock and the ones in greece yes the people of much when lock send money to those games in greece now why well this brings us to the true birthplace of the olympic movement which is the shropshire market town of much whenlock where my parents lived for the best part of 15 years i must be so proud i'm very proud and it's a very big deal in much so one of the london 2012 mascots was called whenlock there were two whenlock and manderville manderville stone manderville being the birthplace of the paralympics
所以这些运动会，有来自英格兰中部一个叫马奇文洛克（Much Wenlock）的小镇捐赠的奖金，而希腊的那场……是的，马奇文洛克的人们向希腊的那些运动会寄送了资金。为什么呢？这就把我们带到了奥林匹克运动真正的诞生地，也就是什罗普郡的集镇马奇文洛克，我的父母在那里住了将近15年。你一定感到非常骄傲。我非常骄傲，而且这在文洛克是一件非常了不起的事。所以伦敦2012年奥运会的吉祥物之一就叫文洛克，有两个，文洛克和曼德维尔（Manderville），曼德维尔是残奥会的发源地。
much whenlock the birthplace of the sort ofmpics, Much Wenlock the birthplace of the summer games, and they have a little museum in Much Wenlock, and you can walk around, there's an Olympic trail, all these sort of things. So genuinely, this is not just Shropshire chauvinism on my part, there's a genuine historical reality here. And basically the guy who started it is a man called, a fascinating man called William Pennybrooks,
马奇文洛克是夏季奥运会的发源地，他们在马奇文洛克有一个小型博物馆，你可以四处走走，有一条奥运步道，诸如此类的事情。所以真的，这不仅仅是我个人的什罗普郡沙文主义，这里有着真正的历史现实。基本上，发起这一切的人是一个名叫——一个迷人的人，名叫威廉·佩尼·布鲁克斯（William Penny Brookes），
who's a classic Victorian kind of do-gooding reformer. So he sets up things like an agricultural reading society. And he has this series of what he calls classes to do different things in the town. And in 1850, he sets up the Olympian class. I mean, this is pure... I think Goldblatt talks about this in his book. And it absolutely gives you a sense of the Victorian mindset
他是一个典型的维多利亚时期的乐善好施的改革家。所以他建立了一些东西，比如农业阅览协会。他开展了一系列他所谓的“课程”，在镇上做不同的事情。1850年，他设立了奥运课程（Olympian class）。我的意思是，这纯粹是……我想戈德布拉特在他的书中谈到了这一点。这绝对让你对奥林匹克运动艺术的维多利亚时期心态有了深刻的感悟，
of the art of the Olympic movement, because the rubric of the Olympian class says, it's set up for the promotion of the moral, physical, and intellectual improvement of the inhabitants of the town and neighbourhood of Much Wenlock, and especially of the working classes, by the encouragement of outdoor recreation and the award of prizes, annulate annual meetings for skill in athletic exercise
因为奥运课程的宗旨写道：它的设立是为了促进马奇文洛克镇及其周边地区居民特别是工人阶级的道德、身体和智力提升，通过鼓励户外休闲和颁发奖项，每年举行会议以奖励在运动锻炼中的技能以及在智力和工业造诣上的精湛表现。
and proficiency in intellectual and industrial attainment. So there you have pure kind of Victorian improvement. And they hold it at a local race course. They have some brilliant events at the first Wenlock Games. So they have football, cricket, they have quoits, running, cycling on penny farthings. Probably fun, wouldn't it? A blindfolded wheelbarrow race. And my favourite event, one that stands comparison, I think, with Dwyle flunking,
所以在这里你看到了纯粹的维多利亚式改良主义。他们在一个当地的赛马场举行比赛。他们在第一届文洛克运动会上有一些精彩的比赛项目。所以他们有足球、板球、掷铁饼（quoits）、赛跑、骑高轮自行车（penny farthings）。可能会很有趣，不是吗？蒙眼推独轮车比赛。我最喜欢的项目，一个我认为可以与倒啤酒游戏相媲美的项目，
an old women's race with the prize being a pound of tea. Again, something I'd like to see at the modern olympics i think there's so much scope for for innovation there isn't there well they're still doing shame that they've all kind of fallen away no but i mean from the from the proper olympics and talking the proper olympics is so dull isn't it well the proper olympics because the way that this influences what comes to be what we now think of as olympics is because baron de coubertin comes and he's he's tremendously impressed so he goes in 1890 he goes to shropshire now this is fascinating coubertin i mean i'm sure you've got lots of stuff about coubertin i think
是一场老年妇女赛跑，奖品是一磅茶。同样，这也是我想在现代奥运会上看到的项目，我认为那里有太多的创新空间，不是吗？好吧，他们仍在举办……很遗憾这些都逐渐没落了。不，但我的意思是，从正规奥运会的角度来看——谈论正规奥运会是如此沉闷，不是吗？好吧，正规奥运会之所以能对我们现在所理解的奥运会产生影响，是因为顾拜旦男爵（Baron de Coubertin）来了，他留下了极其深刻的印象——所以他在1890年去了什罗普郡。现在这很迷人，顾拜旦——我的意思是，我确信你有很多关于顾拜旦的资料，我认为
he's a fascinating guy he's the son of a royalist isn't he a french royalist painter and basically i think what's absolutely central to this is the Franco-Prussian War so he's grown up in the aftermath of the Franco-Prussian War France has been humiliated and all the talk is of you know manliness unity France is so divided of course in the last years of the 19th century
他是一个迷人的人。他是保王党人的儿子，对吧？一个法国保王党画家。基本上，我认为这其中绝对核心的是普法战争。所以他在普法战争结束后长大，法国受到了羞辱，所有的言论都是关于男子气概、团结。在19世纪的最后几年里，法国是如此分裂，
and he becomes obsessed with Tom Brown's school days yes he loved it didn't he because that's the fascinating thing that the inspiration for the Olympics is only very dimly kind of the Hellenic games the original games I mean it is important to Cooper I mean he does have a sense of that kind of the the spiritual dimension that the games had for the Greeks yeah really the influence on him as you say I mean it's the kind of victorian manliness and it absolutely he believes and and the fascinating thing is actually he's got it wrong he thinks thomas arnold the headmaster of rugby was all about sport and muscular christianity and he puts a huge emphasis on this but actually dr arnold wasn't that interested in sport but it's
以至于他痴迷于《汤姆·布朗求学记》（Tom Brown's School Days）。是的，他非常喜欢它，不是吗？因为这是一个迷人的事实，奥运会的灵感仅仅是非常模糊地来源于古希腊运动会、最初的运动会。我的意思是，这对顾拜旦来说很重要，我的意思是，他确实对古希腊人赋予运动会的精神维度有着某种感知——是的，但对他真正产生影响的，正如你所说，是那种维多利亚时代的男子气概。绝对地，他相信——而且引人入胜的事实是，其实他搞错了。他以为拉格鲁（Rugby）学校的校长托马斯·阿诺德（Thomas Arnold）全身心投入于体育运动和肌肉基督教（muscular Christianity），并对此赋予了极大的重视，但实际上阿诺德博士对体育并没有那么感兴趣。
tom brown school days he's confused tom brown school days. He's confused Tom Brown's school days with reality. So Coubertin has read this Tom Brown's school days. He believes that at rugby, men were taught to be men and all this sort of stuff. And so he comes up to Shropshire on this pilgrimage because he thinks this is... And he sees all the old women and wheelbarrows and stuff. And he says, brilliant, this is how we'll beat the prussians
他把《汤姆·布朗求学记》与现实混淆了。所以顾拜旦读了这本《汤姆·布朗求学记》。他相信在拉格鲁学校，男人们被教导要成为真正的男人，诸如此类的事情。因此他带着朝圣的心情来到什罗普郡，因为他认为这就是……然后他看到了所有那些推独轮车的老妇人等等。他说：太棒了，这就是我们下次如何击败普鲁士人的方法，
next time you know because we've been doing quoits we will be prepared um and so he then so i think it's only six years he does it very quickly i mean it's it's not just about kind of preparing for war with the prussians though is it because he's actually very into the the ideal of internationalism yes he is because because when he gives his famous speech in 1892 calling for the olympics to be revived he i mean he let us export rowers runners and fences there is the free trade of the future on the day it is introduced within the walls of old europe the cause of peace will have received a new and mighty stay yeah yeah that's fair i'm being hard on him so that actually i mean that it's kind of internationalist talk of peace yes i guess provides to the modern olympics what the much straight to us the much stranger
你知道的，因为我们一直在玩掷铁饼，我们会做好准备的。所以他随后——我想仅仅过了六年，他行动非常迅速——我的意思是，这不仅仅是关于为与普鲁士人的战争做准备，对吧？因为他实际上非常热衷于国际主义的理想。是的，确实如此。因为当他在1892年发表著名演讲呼吁恢复奥运会时，他说——我的意思是：让我们把赛艇运动员、赛跑运动员和击剑运动员输出去，那是未来的自由贸易。当这一主张在老欧洲的墙内被引入的那一天，和平事业将获得一个新的、强大的支柱。是的，是的，这很公平。我对他的批评有点严厉了，所以实际上，那是一种关于和平的国际主义言论。是的，我猜这为现代奥运会提供了动力，就像那种奇怪得多的、涉及向宙斯献祭100头公牛的精神为古希腊人提供动力一样。
kind of spirit that involves sacrificing 100 oxen to zeus supplied to the to the ancients but isn't it weird though tom you're absolutely right and i think that that spirit that spirit it's very kind of 19th late 19th century globalization isn't it that that and and sort of a descendants of the liberal free trade free ideas all that sort of stuff that was so popular in the mid-19th century um but it has so little in common with the ancient olympics yeah yeah very little i mean basically they take the name they take the torch and they take some of the iconography but the iconography grows up over over a long time yes it does exactly there immediately and and i mean i there are kind of it's structured around patent fantasies.
但这不是很奇怪吗，汤姆？你完全说得对，我认为那种精神——那种精神非常具有19世纪晚期全球化的特征，不是吗？那种自由贸易、自由思想的自由主义者的后代，以及在19世纪中期如此受欢迎的种种理念。但它与古代奥运会有着如此之少的共同点。是的，是的，非常少。基本上，他们借用了名字，借用了火炬，借用了部分标志。但这些标志是经过很长时间才发展起来的。是的，确实如此。并不是立刻就有的。而且，我的意思是，它们围绕着一些根深蒂固的幻想构建。
So there's the idea that it will always be above politics, that it has nothing to do with politics. And right from the beginning, that's mad. It is mad. And actually, I'm sure you noticed this, swatting up for this podcast as I did, that this is an incredibly political story from the beginning. And there's never a of and there's never
比如有一种观点认为它将永远凌驾于政治之上，它与政治毫无关系。从一开始，这就是疯狂的。这太疯狂了。而且，我确信你也注意到了，像我一样为这个podcast做功课时你会发现，这是一个从一开始就极具政治性的故事。从来没有过一个……从来没有过
a moment there's never a moment ever there's never been a moment where the olympics has been separate from politics but also that this kind of ideal of the amateur which he is picking up from tom brown school days and you know british public schools and stiff upper lips and things that that this is a that this is a practical way of organizing sport in an increasingly industrialized mass entertainment era i mean and that that lasts kind of pretty i mean it lasts for decades doesn't it i mean it does it takes a long time to the sort of mid to late 20th century exactly yeah so you're right because of course professional sport already exists so you know yes um particularly which is why the british are not particularly interested in the olympics yeah because it's backward it's sort of pointless
一个时刻，从来没有过任何一个时刻奥运会曾与政治脱节。但同样，这种他从《汤姆·布朗求学记》以及英国公学和坚定不移的绅士风度中汲取的业余精神，在日益工业化的大众娱乐时代，这是一种组织体育运动的实用方式。我的意思是，这种方式持续了相当长的一段时间——我的意思是，它持续了数十年来着，对吧？我的意思是，确实如此，它一直延续到20世纪中后期。完全正确，是的。所以你是对的，因为职业体育当然已经存在了，所以——是的，尤其是这也是为什么英国人对奥运会其实并不怎么感兴趣，
it's sort of like you know when we already have so many professional sports when we're living in a world of wg grace and you know the the football league and and rugby league and all these things the idea of the olympics just seems ridiculously old-fashioned even in the 1890s i think and it's a bit french isn't it it is a bit french but it's so interesting that with all these sporting things it's the british that kind of have the original idea but it takes the french to codify them this is true of football as well fifa and and, you know, it often takes continental Europeans. I think because the British were there first, they generally are just happy to...
因为这很落后，有点毫无意义。这有点像——你知道的，当我们已经有如此多的职业体育时，当我们生活在一个拥有W·G·格雷斯（WG Grace）、足球联赛、橄榄球联盟以及所有这些的世界里时，奥运会的想法即使在1890年代也显得荒谬地过时，而且有点太法国化了。这确实有点法国化。但非常有趣的是，在所有这些体育活动中，最初提出想法的总是英国人，但却需要法国人来将其实际成文规范。足球也是如此，国际足联以及——你知道的，这通常需要欧洲大陆人来做。我想是因为英国人捷足先登，他们通常只是乐于……
Although, Dominic, I mean, a reassuring note from a cricketing point of view is that someone who has joined the IOC, so the initial committee, was actually the captain of the New Zealand cricket team. So steady hand on the tiller there. Has cricket ever been played at the Olympics? Yes, it's played in the second Olympiad, 1900, held in Paris, where there was one match and it was England against France. England was, well, it was Britain, I suppose.
尽管，多米尼克，从板球的角度来看，一个令人欣慰的消息是，加入国际奥委会（IOC）——即最初的委员会——的人之一，实际上是新西兰板球队的队长。所以那里有一个稳健的掌舵人。板球曾被列入过奥运会吗？是的，它在第二届奥运会（1900年巴黎奥运会）上举行过，当时只有一场比赛，是英格兰对阵法国。英格兰——嗯，我想应该是英国。
Britain was represented by a team of strolling players from Devon and Somerset. And France was represented by British expats in Paris. Right. And I'm proud to say that Britain won. But France got the silver medal. So France is a silver medalist. It's the current silver medalist in cricket,
英国由一支来自德文郡和萨默塞特郡的巡回业余球员队伍代表。而法国则由巴黎的英国侨民代表。没错。我很骄傲地宣布，英国赢了。但法国获得了银牌。所以法国是银牌得主。它是板球项目的现任银牌得主，
which is a wonderful detail. Our listeners in Dijon will be delighted by that, won't they? I hope so. I know we're very popular in France. Dominic, of course, Paris is the second one, but the first one is held where else? In Athens. It's kind of interesting.
这是一个绝妙的细节。我们在第戎（Dijon）的听众一定会为此感到高兴，不是吗？希望如此。我知道我们在法国非常受欢迎。多米尼克，当然，巴黎是第二届，但第一届是在哪里举行的呢？在雅典。这挺有意思的。
They never think to hold it actually in Olympia. I think Olympia is a bit of a disappointment there's not actually it takes a long time to excavate so there isn't very much there um whereas athens i guess is kind of more suitable but also athens is the capital isn't it of the newly independent or relatively newly independent greece so it's tied up with ideas of national, you know, must have been tied up with enormous ideas about Greek national pride and so on. I think, I may not have this entirely, but I think the games open
他们从没想过真的在奥林匹亚（Olympia）举办。我想奥林匹亚有点令人失望，那里其实没有进行过大规模的发掘，所以没有什么东西。然而雅典，我猜更合适一些。而且雅典是新独立或相对新独立的希腊的首都，所以它与希腊民族自豪感等巨大的理念紧密相连。我想——我可能记得不是很准——但我认为奥运会是在希腊独立日开幕的。
on Greek Independence Day. Right. And of course, the great innovative race is the marathon. Yeah. Which they run from the grave of the Persians on the plane of marathon where the Athenians had defeated Persia.
没错。当然，最具创新性的比赛是马拉松。是的。他们从马拉松平原上的波斯人墓跑起，雅典人在那里击败了波斯。
And then the news, the story goes that the news is brought to Athens by Pheidippides, who then collapses as he delivers it. And so they restage this race running from the tomb of the Persians all the way into Athens. And it's won by a Greek. This is not an event that they did at the Olympics, right? No, so it's a complete innovation, but it's a tremendous success. And I think that because it's won by Greek, Greece becomes terribly enthusiastic about it as a result, and they're very keen to stage it permanently in athens um but but i think i mean i think it has a kind of um a kind of you know it genuinely is gloriously amateur so there's there's a there's a guy who's there on holiday who enters the tennis and kind of wins the gold
然后消息——故事说，消息由斐迪庇德斯（Pheidippides）带回雅典，他在传达消息时倒地身亡。因此，他们重现了这场比赛，从波斯人墓一直跑进雅典。最后由一名希腊人赢得比赛。这不是他们在古代奥运会上做过的项目，对吧？不，所以这是一个完全的创新，但它取得了巨大的成功。而且我认为，正因为是由希腊人获胜，希腊结果对此产生了巨大的热情，他们非常热衷于将奥运会永久放在雅典举行。但——但我认为它有一种……一种……你知道的，它确实光荣地非常业余。所以有一个人在那里度假，报名参加了网球比赛，结果赢得了金牌。
and there's a brilliant thing about the swimming that um you know they don't have a pool so they hold it in pereas harbor and it's unseasonably cold right so people jump in to do the swimming event and it's so cold that lots of them get back out again and this and actually problems with with swimming events is a theme of the early olympics so in paris in in 1900 they hold it in the same and the currents are so strong there that your medal chances depend on whether you can catch the right current or not. That's great. And at St. Louis in 1904,
关于游泳还有一个精彩的故事，你知道的，他们没有游泳池，所以他们在比雷埃夫斯港（Piraeus harbor）举行游泳比赛，而且当时天气反常地冷。所以人们跳进去参加游泳比赛，结果水太冷了，以至于许多人又爬了上来。其实，游泳比赛中的各种问题是早期奥运会的一个主题。所以在1900年的巴黎，他们在塞纳河（Seine）举行比赛，那里的水流非常湍急，以至于你的夺牌几率取决于你是否能抓住正确的水流。这太棒了。在1904年的圣路易斯，
two of the gold medal winning US water polo team die six months after the event because they've contracted typhoid from the lagoon in which the water polo had been played so it's you pay a high price for elite sporting achievement you really you really do um but i i think that that the sense of kind of shambolic amateurism that is a kind of you know it's a quality of the first games in athens is it's it's the one in paris that absolutely exemplifies it yeah the reason for that is that it's it's the one in Paris that absolutely exemplifies it yeah the
赢得金牌的美国水球队中有两名成员在赛后六个月内去世了，因为他们感染了举办水球比赛的泻湖里的伤寒。所以为了精英体育的成就，你付出了高昂的代价。你真的付出了高昂代价……但我认为，那种混乱的业余主义感——那是第一届雅典奥运会的一种特质——正是巴黎奥运会绝对典型地体现了这一点。是的，巴黎奥运会之所以如此，原因在于
reason for that is that it's piggybacking onto the world exhibition that is being held in Paris isn't that the case with a lot of these early olympics they're basically all arranged around St Louis yes and actually you know so that goes back to Crystal Palace and the great exhibition yeah this idea that you have a great gathering of people from across the world and you showcase your your city and your country with it well remember that uh william penny brooks's thing at watch wenlock see bringing it back to shropshire was that um prizes would also be awarded for proficiency in intellectual and industrial attainments so that's very i mean this is a year before the great exhibition so it's very much that victorian sort of spirit that, as you say,
它依附于在巴黎举行的世界博览会。许多早期奥运会不都是这种情况吗？它们基本上都是围绕着——比如圣路易斯。是的，事实上，这就回到了水晶宫和万国博览会。这种理念是，你聚集了来自世界各地的人们，并通过它来展示你的城市和国家。好吧，记住威廉·佩尼·布鲁克斯在马奇文洛克做的事——把话题拉回什罗普郡——那就是奖品也将颁发给在智力和工业造诣上有精湛表现的人。所以这非常——我的意思是，这比万国博览会早了一年，所以这非常符合那种维多利亚式的精神，正如你所说，
the trade fairs, therefore, are not an illegitimate, you know, they're part of the essence from the beginning. And that's something that we now... Absolutely. Well, I think, yes, I think, I mean, I think they structure the whole idea of the Olympics as we understand it now. I mean, that's a crucial part of it. And part of the problem for Coubertin and the Olympic movement is that people are going to Paris for the trade
因此，贸易展并非不合法，它们从一开始就是其本质的一部分。而这是我们现在……完全如此。好吧，我想，是的，我认为——我认为它们构成了我们现在所理解的整个奥运会的理念。我的意思是，那是其中至关重要的一部分。而对顾拜旦和奥林匹克运动来说，部分问题在于人们去巴黎是为了参加贸易展，根本不知道奥运会正在举行。因此有这样一个美妙的——可能是我有史以来最喜欢的奥运选手，一个名叫玛格丽特·阿博特（Margaret Abbott）的美国女性，当时在巴黎跟随德加、罗丹学习。她是一名艺术家。
fair and they have no idea that the Olympics are going on and so there's this kind of wonderful probably my favorite Olympian of all time is an American woman called Margaret Abbott who is in Paris studying with Degas, with Rodin. She's an artist. And she gets told, yeah, there's this golf contest going on. Would you like to enter it? Yeah, okay, great. So she enters the golf. She wins.
有人告诉她：“哦，那里有个高尔夫比赛正在进行。你想参加吗？”“好啊，太棒了。”所以她去参加了高尔夫比赛。她赢了。
She has no idea that she's won gold in the golf contest, that she is America's first gold medal, female gold medal winner. And she dies in 1955. And people still don't know. So she dies never knowing that she's been an Olympic gold medalist. And I think it's only kind of in the 70s or 80s when historians of the Olympics go through and work this out,
她根本不知道自己在高尔夫比赛中赢得了金牌，不知道自己是美国第一位获得金牌的女性金牌得主。她在1955年去世时，人们仍然一无所知。所以她直到去世都不知道自己曾是一位奥运会金牌得主。我想直到20世纪70年代或80年代，奥运会历史学家们通过翻阅资料查清了这件事，
that she gets enshrined in this role, which, you know, kind of brilliantly shows how symbolic the whole affair is um there's and the other kind of very haunting story from the the paris olympics is that um the dutch rowing team uh they don't have a cox i think the cox falls ill or something and so they scoop a french boy back who's about 10 you know one of the canals or something and he coxes them and i think again i think they win they get the gold medal but nobody knows who this boy is so he's he's the only gold medal winning olympian who is anonymous so that's great stuff isn't it did he know he'd won did he even know himself what he was doing just some blokes had put him on their boats and said not sure i don't know um wow so all good
她才被正式确立在这个角色中，这（你知道的）极其巧妙地展示了整个事件是多么具有象征意义。还有一个非常挥之不去的、来自巴黎奥运会的故事，那就是荷兰赛艇队——他们没有舵手，我想舵手生病了或者怎么回事，于是他们在运河里顺手捞了一个大约10岁的法国小男孩，或者别的什么地方的人，让他当他们的舵手。我想同样地，他们赢了，他们获得了金牌。但没有人知道这个男孩是谁，所以他是唯一匿名的奥运金牌得主。这不是很棒的内容吗？他知道自己赢了吗？他甚至知道自己在做什么吗？只是一些家伙把他拉上了他们的船，说：“我不确定，我不知道。”哇，所以全都是好内容。
stuff um but the greatest race of all time is the marathon that was raced in st louis in 1904 and i think we should have a break shouldn't we absolutely we should have a break because i'm gonna come back can i tell you about that because i think it's tell me at great length because i know you love this story brilliant and then and then basically my knowledge of the Olympics is exhausted. I'll hand the baton over to you. I do not believe that's true. All right, we'll take a break and we'll come back for the greatest marathon of all time. I'm Marina Hyde.
但有史以来最伟大的比赛是1904年在圣路易斯举行的马拉松比赛。我想我们该休息一下了，对吧？绝对的，我们应该休息一下，因为我要回来——我能跟你讲讲那个故事吗？因为我认为——请详细地讲给我听，因为我知道你喜欢这个故事。太棒了，然后基本上我对奥运会的知识就用尽了。我把接力棒交给你。我不相信这是真的。好吧，我们休息一下，然后回来讲述有史以来最伟大的马拉松比赛。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝秀场八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告广播、加更节目和抢先购买现场门票的机会，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》。汤姆·霍兰德对他的马拉松故事寄予了厚望。我非常期待听到它。汤姆，请不负它的精彩。好吧，他们拍过《烈火战车》（Chariots of Fire），但老实说，如果你要拍一部电影，这就是你想拍的比赛。我认为这是奥运会历史上最伟大的比赛。
access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Tom Holland has made great claims for his marathon story. I am so looking forward to hearing it. Tom, please do it justice. Well, they made Chariots of Fire, but honestly, if you're making a film, this is the race that you'd want to do. I think it's the greatest race in Olympics history.
1904年在圣路易斯举行，那里非常炎热、非常闷热、非常多尘。组织者们将马拉松的路线设计为——我想在比赛进行到12英里处有一个饮水机，但除此之外没有任何水源。这时比赛已经有26英里长了吗？因为他们……是的。而且科学家们想要测量脱水对精英运动员的影响——所以这就是背景，所以这也是乐趣的一部分。因此，我将描述一些参赛选手，以及他们跑步时的名次。
Raced it in 1984 at St. Louis, which is very hot, very sticky, very dusty. And the organisers, they make the marathon along a route where there is, I think, a single water cooler 12 miles into the race, but otherwise there is no source of water and is it 26 miles at this point because they're yeah and there are scientists want to measure the effects of dehydration on elite athletes so that that's the context so that's part of the fun so so i will describe some of the contestants who the positions where they run.
所以第一个冲过终点线的人是一个名叫弗雷德·洛茨（Fred Lortz）的家伙，他是一名泥瓦匠，也是一个臭名昭著的恶作剧者。他被授予了金牌。随后人们发现他在一辆卡车后面搭了9英里的便车。所以他的奖牌被剥夺了，而他说：“我只是开个玩笑，只是开个玩笑。”所以下一个冲过终点线、因而顺理成章有望赢得奖牌的人是一个名叫托马斯·希克斯（Thomas Hicks）的家伙，他是一名职业选手——你知道的，他是一名经验丰富的马拉松运动员。他的教练看出希克斯开始体力不支了，于是给他提供了一种精英运动饮料。所以有点像——你知道的，冰淇淋的替代品。
So the guy who comes in first is a guy called Fred Lortz, who is a bricklayer and a notorious practical joker. He is awarded the gold medal. And it then turns out that he's hitched nine mile lift on the back of a truck. So he gets stripped of his medal and he says i'll just have a laugh just have a laugh so the next person who comes in who then is in line for winning the medal is a guy called thomas hicks who is a professional you know he's he's a seasoned marathon runner um he has a coach who can see that that hicks isging, so gives him an elite sports drink. So kind of, you know, the equivalent of an ice cream.
力保健（Lucozade）。力保健。但你知道它里面包含什么吗？它包含蛋白、白兰地和士的宁（strychnine，一种剧毒生物碱）。天哪。我没想到会有士的宁。是的。所以他跌跌撞撞地走向终点柱。
Lucasade. Lucasade. But do you know what it consists of? It consists of egg whites, brandy, and strychnine. Oh, my God. I didn't expect the strychnine. No. So he's staggering towards the final post.
他喝下了这大口大口的士的宁，开始神志不清，并开始四处乱走、走错方向。所以他必须被引导向终点线，人们不得不字面意义上——你知道的，他的助手们不得不字面意义上抬起他的双脚，因为到了这个时候他已经完全不省人事了。所以他赢了，他成了奖牌得主。
He gets this great glug of strychnine, and he starts to go delirious and starts kind of wandering off all the wrong way so he has to be guided towards the finish line and people have to literally you know his helpers have to literally lift his feet up because by this point he's absolutely out of it so he wins he he is the medal winner um coming in number four is a cuban postman called felix carvajal right who who's in cuba he runs up and down cuba that's what he does for fun and he he hitches a lift on a boat from cuba to america um he loses all his money gambling so he turns up at St Louis he doesn't have any any cash to buy running gear so he comes to the start of the race in his brogues in his kind of thick heavy trousers he's got a beret on
获得第四名的是一个名叫菲利克斯·卡瓦哈尔（Felix Carvajal）的古巴邮递员。他在古巴经常在古巴跑来跑去，那是他的消遣。他搭乘了一艘从古巴开往美国的船。他在赌博时输光了所有的钱，所以他到达圣路易斯时没有任何现金来购买跑步装备。因此他穿着布洛克鞋（brogues）、厚重的长裤来到起跑线上，戴着贝雷帽，穿着宽松的白衬衫。我的意思是，他再怎么不具备跑步装备也不过如此了。其中另一位参赛选手对他产生怜悯，割掉了他裤子的下摆，这样到了那个时候他实际上穿着短裤。他出发了，在不同的地方停下来——我想他从一棵树上偷了一些杏子。那算是一种兴奋剂吗？当然不算。他吃了一些生的苹果，结果肚子不舒服。他一路上都在停下来跟人们聊天，但他获得了第四名。
he's got a baggy white shirt I mean he couldn't be less well equipped to run it one of the other contenders takes pity on him and chops off the bottoms of his trousers so that he's kind of wearing running shorts by this point he he sets off he stops at various points to he he nicks I think some um apricots from a from from a tree is that an artificial stimulant surely not he he eats some some apples that are raw so he gets upset he's stopping the whole way to kind of chat with people but he comes in fourth yeah so that's a that's a great creditable achievement but the the the in a way the most creditable achievement of all is um a guy called len tau len tau who comes len, he comes from South Africa, or to be specific, from a tribe in South Africa. And he is there as part of probably the most sinister aspect of these international affairs. Oh, I know what you're going to say.
所以这是一个了不起的、值得称赞的成就。但其中——在某种程度上，最值得称赞的成就是……一个名叫兰·陶（Len Tau）的家伙，他来自南非，确切地说，来自南非的一个部族。他是作为这些国际事务中最具阴暗色彩的一面的一部分而来到这里的。哦，我知道你要说什么了。
So they had this in Paris and they have it in St. Louis. The Department of Anthropology have set this up. Yeah, it's human zoos. So they have this in Paris and they have it in st louis they they bring people over from various parts of the colonial empire and in america they bring native americans over as well they kind of put them up in villages and what they do in st louis is um they have this um idea that they want to they want to measure the athletic capacity of people they see as inferior so it's i think that the kind of the press in america call them the savage olympics
所以他们在巴黎也有这个，在圣路易斯也有。人类学系设立了这一切。是的，那是人类动物园。他们在巴黎和圣路易斯都有这个，他们从殖民帝国的各个地方把人带过来，在美国，他们也把美洲原住民带过来。他们把他们安置在村庄里，而在圣路易斯，他们做的事情是……他们有一个想法，想要测量他们视为低等的人的运动能力。所以我想美国的媒体称他们为“野蛮人奥运会”。
and they get all these guys from out of the human zoos and they you know that these people have never done weightlifting or you know anything and and and they're made to compete and they don't do very well and so this is taken as proof that that white people are more proficient at athletics than than everyone else um but lent out enters the uh enters the marathon and he he races barefoot um comes in ninth but that is all the more creditable because while he's running the marathon he gets attacked by a dog and has to run an extra mile to escape it wow so i think i think he he is my moral victor isn't he he's the absolute moral victor well it's a great that is a great team we're talking moral victors you know
他们把所有人从人类动物园里弄出来，你知道的，这些人从来没有做过举重或者任何类似的事情，然后被迫参赛。他们表现得不是很好，所以这被视为白人在田径运动上比其他人更熟练的证据。但兰·陶参加了马拉松比赛，他光着脚跑步，最终获得了第九名。但这一切更加值得称赞，因为当他在跑马拉松时，遭到了一只狗的袭击，不得不额外多跑了一英里来逃跑。哇，我想——我认为他是我的道德胜者，不是吗？他绝对是道德上的胜者。好吧，这是一个伟大的……当我们谈论道德胜者时，你知道的，
the marathon in the next olympics 1908 there's a great story there about a man called, do you know about this Durando Pietri, Tom? No. So he's a, he's very short. He's five foot two. He's a shop boy, a confectionery shop boy from Italy. And where is this one being held? So this is 1908, which is. Is it Antwerp? No, it's London. Oh, London.
下一届奥运会（1908年）的马拉松赛有一个很棒的故事，关于一个名叫——你知道这个叫多兰多·皮耶特里（Dorando Pietri）的人吗，汤姆？不知道。所以他个子非常矮，只有五尺二寸（约157厘米）。他是一个店员，来自意大利的一名糖果店学员。这场比赛在哪里举行？所以这是1908年，也就是……是安特卫普吗？不，是伦敦。哦，伦敦。
Yes, of course. Yes, White City. They build White City. So. Yeah. is that antwerp no it's london oh london yes of course yes white city they build white city so yeah so he um has entered a a race in italy he saw a race in italy in 94 years earlier and he was still in he was dressed in his work clothes he was going to work or something and he saw the race going by and he thought he'd join in and he came and he did really well i think he won it actually so he started to run marathons and stuff and he he trains really hard for the um for the 1908 olympics he runs the
是的，当然。对，白城（White City）。他们建造了白城。所以。对，那是安特卫普吗？不，是伦敦。哦，伦敦，对，当然，对，白城，他们建造了白城，所以，对，所以他，嗯，参加了意大利的一场比赛，他在四年前的94年看到了一场意大利的比赛，当时他还在，他穿着工作服，他正要去上班什么的，他看到比赛队伍经过，就想加入，于是他就去了，而且表现得非常好，我想他甚至赢了。所以他开始跑马拉松之类的，他为1908年的奥运会进行了非常刻苦的训练，他跑了
marathon and it's incredibly hot day it's an unseasonably hot day and he he overtakes the leader just before the end and then he get they come into the the stadium or whatever and there's a very famous photo you've probably seen it without knowing it yeah um he keeps collapsing and the crowd are cheering him on and he's collapsing and he's almost at the line there are 75 000 people there i think he falls four times and eventually right at the finish line the he collapses again and the umpires have to lift him up and and sort of drag him over the line and he's disqualified despite the fact that he's won so what then happens is um queen alexandra gives him a gilded silver cup as a as a reward you know to say you know well done you and sir arthur conan doyle writes an article about him about his heroism for the Daily Mail. It's a big article.
马拉松，那是一个热得难以置信的日子，是一个反常的热天，他在快到终点时超越了领先者，然后他们进入了体育场什么的，有一张非常著名的照片，你可能没认出来就见过，对，嗯，他不断地倒下，人群为他加油，他不断地倒下，眼看就要到终点线了，那里有75,000人，我想他摔倒了四次，最终就在终点线前，他又倒下了，裁判们不得不把他扶起来，几乎是拖着他过了终点线，尽管他赢了，他还是被取消了资格。接下来发生的事情是，亚历山大王后（Queen Alexandra）授予了他一个镀金银杯作为奖励，你知道的，以此来表示“干得好，你”，亚瑟·康纳·多伊尔爵士（Sir Arthur Conan Doyle）为《每日邮报》写了一篇关于他的英雄主义的文章。这是一篇大文章。
First with the big sports stories. All the best people have written about the Olympics in the Daily Mail, Tom. So Arthur Conador writes about him in the Daily Mail. The Daily Mail readers, with their characteristic generosity, start an appeal for him. They raise the equivalent of £30,000 for this man. And he goes back to italy and he uses it to open a bakery that's a wonderful everybody comes out of that well
首先播报重大体育新闻。所有最好的人都在《每日邮报》上写过关于奥运会的内容，汤姆。所以亚瑟·康纳·多伊尔（Sir Arthur Conador）在《每日邮报》上写了关于他的文章。《每日邮报》的读者们以其特有的慷慨，为他发起了一场募捐。他们为这个人筹集了相当于30,000英镑的资金。他回到了意大利，并用这笔钱开了一家面包店，这是一个美好的结局，每个人都有个好归宿。
um well except that isn't there isn't the context of that also a deep strain of of british anti-americanism because the it's it's an american i think who wins it is the race and there's there's a lot of kind of um american sneering at the the decadence of british yes so everyone comes out of this well except the americans i think maybe yes yes many people that yeah yeah but perhaps um but and so that's the context for the London Games. Yeah. And then you have Stockholm. Stockholm, the next one. I sort of lose my... Okay, but Stockholm is important
嗯，好吧，除了那里，难道其中没有一种深层的英国反美主义情绪吗？因为，这是一个美国人，我想，赢得这场比赛，并且有很多对英国人颓废的美国式的冷嘲热讽，是的，所以每个人都有个好归宿，除了美国人，我想也许吧，是的，是的，许多人，对，对，但也许，嗯，但是，这就是伦敦奥运会的背景。对。然后就是斯德哥尔摩。斯德哥尔摩，下一届。我有点忘了……好吧，但斯德哥尔摩很重要
just because that's the first one to be held without reference to a trade fair. Right, 1912. So it kind of emancipates itself from that. And then, of course, you have the First World War. Loads of Olympians die in the war and then it's Antwerp
仅仅因为那是第一届不与贸易博览会联合举办的奥运会。对吧，1912年。所以它某种程度上将自身解放出来了。然后，当然，你还有第一次世界大战。大批奥运选手在战争中牺牲，然后是安特卫普，
is that right? then it's Antwerp and then it's Paris so Paris is the Chariots of Fire games so tell us about that for those who haven't seen it the Chariots of Fire really focuses David Putnam discovered a book I think in 1977 the film producer
是这样吗？然后是安特卫普，然后是巴黎，所以巴黎是《烈火战车》（Chariots of Fire）的奥运会，所以给我们讲讲那个，对于那些没看过的人来说，《烈火战车》主要讲述了戴维·普特纳姆（David Putnam）在1977年发现的一本书，我想，这位电影制片人
he was in Malibu, and he had a cold or something, so he was staying in a borrowed house, and he was really miserable. And he reached for a book off the shelves, and it was the story of the Olympics, I think. I think it was the history of the Olympics. And he became fixated on the story of the 1924 Games,
他当时在马里布，感冒了还是怎么的，所以他住在借来的房子里，非常痛苦。他随手从书架上拿了一本书，那好像是奥运会的故事。我想那是奥运会的历史。他开始迷恋1924年奥运会的故事，
which has these two iconic British competitors, Harold Abrahams, who is Jewish, who is the son of a Jewish immigrant, who wins the 100 metres, but has raised hackles with the sort of, the patrician officials back in Britain because he employs a professional coach, an Italian, Sam Mussabini.
其中有两位标志性的英国选手，哈罗德·亚伯拉罕斯（Harold Abrahams），他是犹太人，是一个犹太移民的儿子，他赢得了100米比赛，但由于他雇用了职业教练——一个意大利人萨姆·穆萨比尼（Sam Mussabini），他惹恼了英国那些保守的官员。
And the other great athlete who is, you know, we need no introduction, is Eric Liddle, the brilliant Scottish runner musabini and the other great athlete who is you know we need no introduction is eric little the brilliant scottish runner who refuses to run in 100 meters heats because they're on a sunday and he believes that's sacred so he runs um in the i think the 400 meters instead and wins gold and you know if anyone who i'm personally i i I'm one of, because I'm a sort of sentimental person, I find it hard to watch Chariots of Fire without getting kind of choked up, particularly the sort of, the sort of, the completely unironic and sort of sincere treatment of Liddell's religious faith
而另一位伟大的运动员，你知道的，无需多做介绍，就是埃里克·利德尔（Eric Liddle），那位才华横溢的苏格兰跑步运动员。穆萨比尼，而另一位伟大的运动员，你知道的，无需多做介绍，就是埃里克·利德尔，那位才华横溢的苏格兰跑步运动员，他拒绝在100米预赛中出场，因为比赛在周日举行，而他认为这是神圣的，所以他参加了，我想是400米比赛并赢得了金牌，你知道的，如果任何人，就我个人而言，我是一个有些多愁善感的人，我发现看《烈火战车》时很难不感到哽咽，尤其是那种，那种对利德尔宗教信仰完全不加讽刺的、真诚的处理方式
and how important it is to him and how he sees his athletic prowess as a gift from God. And this wonderful story that an American competitor before the race sort of leaves him a note that says, you know, whoever honors me, I will honor. And Lidl uses this as inspiration. And of course, Lidl then goes on after having won gold and having become a national hero, he goes on to leave athletics completely
以及这对他是多么重要，他是如何将自己的运动天赋视为上帝的恩赐的。还有一个精彩的故事，一个美国选手在比赛前给他留了一张便条，上面写着：“凡尊重我的，我必重看他。”利德尔将此作为灵感。当然，利德尔在赢得金牌并成为民族英雄之后，完全退出了田径界，
and to become a missionary in China and ends his days in a Japanese internment camp where he dies just before the end of the war. So he is a genuinely... We do a lot of people with feet of clay in this podcast, but I'm not convinced he did have feet of clay, actually. I think he's a genuinely incredibly admirable um an impressive man so there you go uh well there is um also in the 1924 olympics i think is the first irish winner um not per se because the the guy who um who won the tennis in the 1896 say the athens games was was
去中国当了一名传教士，并在一个日本集中营里度过了他人生的最后几天，他在战争结束前不久去世了。所以他是一个真正的人……我们在播客中讨论过很多有这样那样缺点的人，但我并不确信他真的有什么缺点。我认为他是一个真正令人难以置信的、令人钦佩的、了不起的人，所以，就是这样，嗯，还有，嗯，在1924年奥运会上，我想也是第一个爱因斯坦……不对，是第一个爱尔兰获胜者，并非原本意义上的，因为赢得1896年网球比赛的那个人，也就是雅典奥运会，是
irish irish nationalist uh the london games there was um an irish competitor who won gold the union jack went up and he replaced it with the uh the irish flag but the first person to win it as you know the free state was the uh the younger brother of the poet w.B. Yeats, who won silver for painting. So they were still doing... Yeah. They should still do painting, shouldn't they? And it's interesting because Yeats, Yeats's brother was,
爱尔兰民族主义者。伦敦奥运会上，有，嗯，一个爱尔兰选手赢得了金牌，英国国旗升起了，他用，嗯，爱尔兰国旗将其替换。但正如你所知，第一个以“自由邦”名义赢得比赛的人，是诗人W.B.叶芝（W.B. Yeats）的弟弟，他为绘画项目赢得了银牌。所以他们当时还在搞……是的。他们现在应该还在搞绘画，对吧？有趣的是，叶芝，叶芝的弟弟，
he did lots of cartoons for Punch and he did a strip cartoon parodying Sherlock Holmes. So a kind of, you know of improbable Olympic victor. But he then, apparently he's a very highly rated artist. I think strip cartoonists, I think like Stan Lee should have entered the United States in the 60s or something. So that's all fun. And then you have Amsterdam.
他为《笨拙》（Punch）杂志画了许多漫画，他还画过一部讽刺福尔摩斯的连环漫画。所以这是一个，你知道的，不太可能的奥运冠军。但他后来，显然是一个评价极高的艺术家。我想连环漫画家，我觉得就像斯坦·李（Stan Lee）应该在60年代左右参加美国队一样。所以这都很有趣。然后是阿姆斯特丹。
And then you have, in the 30s, you have two games that essentially... Create the Olympics. Create the the Olympics as we know them so and and these are chiefly interesting for the fact that my great uncle competed in them is that are they chiefly interesting are you sure you've chosen your words yeah they're chiefly interesting for that reason chiefly interesting so my great great uncle uh charles holland amazing cyclist went to la came 15th then in the 1936 berlin olympics came fourth but he would have cut he would have come first except that the foreigners cheated by having gears oh that is cheating and great uncle charlie being british refused to use gears because he viewed it as so he's the moral victor isn't it I think so so I'm the great nephew basically of a great moral yeah a great Olympian
然后，在30年代，你有两届奥运会，它们基本上……创造了奥运会。创造了我们所知的奥运会。所以，这些奥运会主要有趣的地方在于，我的曾叔祖父参加了它们。它们真的很有趣吗？你确定你选对词了吗？是的，它们主要就因为这个有趣。主要有趣。所以我的曾曾叔祖父，查尔斯·霍兰德（Charles Holland），了不起的自行车手，去了洛杉矶，得了第15名，然后在1936年柏林奥运会上得了第4名，但他本该得第一名的，如果不是那些外国人通过使用齿轮作弊的话。哦，那确实是作弊。而查利曾叔祖父身为英国人，拒绝使用齿轮，因为他认为这……所以他是道德上的胜者，对吧？我想是的。所以基本上我是一个伟大的道德楷模，一个伟大的奥运选手的曾侄孙。
uh you're right obviously there are other aspects of the LA and the Berlin games but you know LA is the home of Hollywood so Hollywood in its pomp and the idea that it's show business and yeah absolutely but and then you have but but it's run on a shoestring because this is the great depression and there's there's so la creates the podium doesn't it la they they get basically with the hollywood razzmatazz they invent the podium they start playing national this has this surprised me because in chariots of fire the film the playing of the British National Anthem is a key moment because it's the moment that Sam Mussabini, Harold Abraham's coach,
嗯，你说的对，显然洛杉矶和柏林奥运会还有其他方面，但你知道，洛杉矶是好莱坞的故乡，所以好莱坞正处于鼎盛时期，这是一个充满演艺界色彩的想法，是的，绝对是这样。但是，它的资金却非常拮据，因为这是大萧条时期，所以洛杉矶创造了领奖台，不是吗？洛杉矶，他们基本上借助好莱坞的花哨作风，发明了领奖台，他们开始演奏国歌。这让我感到惊讶，因为在电影《烈火战车》中，演奏英国国歌是一个关键时刻，因为那是萨姆·穆萨比尼——哈罗德·亚伯拉罕斯的教练——
because he's too nervous to watch the race, so he only knows his man has won when he hears the British National Anthem. But I now discover that in 1932, they introduced National Anthems for the first time, so this could not have happened. Also, the flame, the flame in the cauldron. I mean, that's a very Hollywood touch.
因为他太紧张而不敢看比赛，所以他只有在听到英国国歌响起时，才知道自己的人赢了。但我现在发现，在1932年，他们首次引入了国歌，所以这本是不可能发生的。还有火炬，火炬盆里的火焰。我的意思是，那是非常好莱坞式的点缀。
And that's Los Angeles. So they didn't do that in the ancient Olympics, Tom. They didn't have an Olympic flame then. Or did they have a torch or anything like that? No. That's all utter bilge. That's all, yeah. I mean, that's the most famous little-known fact about the Olympics, isn't it?
那是洛杉矶。所以在古代奥运会上他们并没有这样做，汤姆。那时候他们没有奥运圣火。或者他们当时有火炬之类的东西吗？没有。那全都是废话。那全都是，是的。我的意思是，那是关于奥运会最著名却鲜为人知的事实，不是吗？
Yes, I suppose so. That people always bring up. Not famous to me, yeah. I mean, that's the most famous little-known fact about the Olympics, isn't it? Yes, I suppose so. That people always bring up. Not famous to me, clearly. But the person, you know, the guys who invent the idea of the torch relay from Olympia to the games is the Nazis. They're not good guys. And there's a case for saying that really the template for the modern games as we know them now you know it's it's the most enduring cultural expression of absolutely agree with you yeah that we have completely agree with you um i think it's an extraordinary thing isn't it that people talk about the 1936 games as though they
是的，我想是的。人们总是提起这件事。对我来说不著名，是的。我的意思是，那是关于奥运会最著名却鲜为人知的事实，不是吗？是的，我想是的。人们总是提起件事。对我来说显然不著名。但那个发明了从奥林匹亚到奥运会的火炬接力创意的人，你知道的，是纳粹。他们可不是什么好人。有理由认为，现代奥运会的模板——正如我们今天所知的那样，你知道的，它是我们拥有的最具持久力的文化表达——我完全同意你的看法，是的。我们完全同意，嗯，我认为这是一件非凡的事情，不是吗？人们把1936年的奥运会谈得好像它们
are an anomaly um as though they are the sort of great well i mean they are they are a blot on there they are a stain on the record of the olymp But I completely agree with you. They are the moment that the modern Olympics really began. Because the Nazis and Leni Riefenstahl and the way they are packaged, that creates the template for all subsequent Olympics. And indeed, that's sort of, in a way, that the fascism isn't an anomaly because there is a kind of commonality between the sort of the nazi aesthetic in the 1930s and the sort of victorian worship of manliness virility but also it's proper you know it's properly uh you know there is a kind of greek element an authentically greek element
是一个例外，好像它们是某种伟大的——我的意思是，它们确实是，它们是奥运会历史上的一大污点。但我完全同意你的看法。它们是现代奥运会真正开始的时刻。因为纳粹、莱尼·里芬斯塔尔（Leni Riefenstahl）以及他们的包装方式，为后来的所有奥运会创造了模板。事实上，在某种程度上，法西斯主义并不是一个例外，因为20世纪30年代的纳粹美学与维多利亚时代对男子气概、阳刚之气的崇拜之间存在着某种共通性，但它也是恰如其分的，你知道的，它恰如其分地，你知道的，其中有一种希腊元素，一种真实的希腊元素，
with the assumption that that what is physically beautiful is morally beautiful and that's you know that's very much a kind of fascist idea absolutely yeah that the body beautiful so the kind you know the famous um image in the film of the uh the classical statue of the discus thrower yes becoming living flesh that's what the essence you know of of those 36 the 1936 games is and all the kind of hellenic flummery that they throw in so that the the the the torch race the significance of that is that the nazis are casting themselves as the kin of the aryan greeks who had set up the olympics and when the torch comes into, first enters the Reich, it does it at a village called Hellendorf. So Hellas, you know, is the Greek name for Greece. So it's all kind of absolutely pinpoint synchronization to convey to the world that Germany is the heir of classical Greece. Yeah. And they're not really very interested, obviously,
伴随着一种假设：即外表美丽的东西在道德上也是美丽的，你知道的，这非常像一种法西斯式的想法。绝对是的，也就是对健美身体的崇拜。所以，你知道电影中那个著名的画面——掷铁饼者的古典雕像，是的，变成了有血有肉的生命。这就是36年奥运会——1936年奥运会的本质所在，以及他们所加入的所有古希腊式的浮华仪式。所以火炬接力的意义在于，纳粹把自己塑造成了雅利安希腊人的同类，而雅利安希腊人正是奥运会的创立者。当火炬进入——首次进入德意志帝国时，它是在一个叫做海伦多夫（Hellendorf）的村庄进行的。所以赫拉斯（Hellas），你知道的，是希腊的希腊语名称。所以这一切都进行了绝对精确的同步，向世界传达这样一个信息：德国是古典希腊的继承人。是的。而且很显然，他们并不是非常感兴趣，
in the kind of universalist dreams and ideals that Coubertin had embodied. I mean, they kind of, they have to agree to let Jews compete. And actually, a number of Jews get goals. They do. And there's Jews, for example, there's a German fencer, Helen Meyer. They keep her on the team.
对顾拜旦（Coubertin）所体现的那些普世主义的梦想和理想。我的意思是，他们某种程度上，他们不得不同意让犹太人参赛。事实上，许多犹太人获得了奖牌。他们确实得到了。而且有犹太人，例如，有一个德国击剑手海伦·迈尔（Helen Meyer）。他们把她留在了队伍里。
She's Jewish. They keep her on the team and they use her as evidence that actually they're much kinder and cuddlier than their foreign critics allow. So they sort of say, oh, look, we're much more tolerant. And they do all these kinds of things.
她是犹太人。他们把她留在了队伍里，并以此作为证据，证明实际上他们比外国批评者所认为的要善良和友好得多。所以他们会说，哦，看，我们更加宽容。他们做了所有这些类似的事情。
So they ban the publication of their Stürmer, the Nazi newspapers kept off the streets of Berlin. They do all this kind of manicuring of the regime. Banned authors reappearing in bookshops. Exactly, all this sort of stuff. And actually, there's some really fascinating books being written about the 1936 Games, talking about all the american and british visitors
所以他们禁止出版他们的《突击队员》（Stürmer）杂志，纳粹报纸被禁止在柏林的街道上出现。他们对政权进行了所有这种精心粉饰。被禁的作家重新出现在书店里。没错，所有诸如此类的事情。事实上，有一些关于1936年奥运会的非常迷人的书籍正在被撰写，谈到了所有那些美国和英国的游客，
um who arrive and are completely taken in you know they they pitch up and they say the answers aren't as bad as they appear you know things are not the night life in the nightclubs is is great um you know even though just outside the city uh people are even then political political prisoners even then building the Sachsenhausen concentration camp and I think Germany has just re-militarised the Rhineland
嗯，他们到达那里并完全被蒙蔽了，你知道的，他们到达后说，情况并没有想象的那么糟，你知道的，事情并非如此，夜总会里的夜生活非常棒，你知道的，尽管就在城市外面，人们甚至在当时就已经成了政治犯，甚至在当时就已经在建造萨克森豪森（Sachsenhausen）集中营了，而且我想德国刚刚将莱茵兰非军事化，
so Hitler's intentions are kind of clear there's no doubt about the nature of the regime but people it's the template for people deluding themselves using the Olympic Games to template for people deluding themselves using the olympic games to almost willfully delude themselves about the nature of the the host nation so i mean they were amazing story there's this a woman who famously gives hitler a kiss um two american tourists they kind of event come to the games and they and they go in and this woman um she she's
所以希特勒的意图其实很明显，这个政权的本质毫无疑问，但人们——这就是人们自我欺骗的模板，利用奥运会——这成了人们自我欺骗的模板，几乎是故意地对主办国的本质进行自我欺骗。所以，我的意思是，有一个惊人的故事，有一个女人因为给了希特勒一个吻而闻名，两个美国游客，他们来到奥运会上，然后他们进去了，这个女人，她
quite close to him in the stadium. And she goes over sort of spontaneously. She sees a chance just when his security guards have their backs turned. And she goes and kisses him. And the image goes around the world. And she goes back to America. And she becomes a bit, it's California, I think. And she becomes a bit of a celebrity.
在体育场里离他相当近。她有点自发地走了过去。当她看到一个机会，正好他的安保人员背对着她时。她走了过去吻了他。这个画面传遍了世界。然后她回到了美国。她变得有点——我想那是加利福尼亚州。她成了一个有点名气的人物。
And I've always wondered what happened to her after the war or what point she yeah you wouldn't want that on your facebook page would you that is cancellation we're going to remove that cancellation worthy that that would be a problem um and i i get i mean so the famous the famous story is jesse owens yeah wins four four medals is it four medals four medal and obviously Four medals? Four medals. And obviously it's black. And that plays very... So south of the Mason-Dixon line, no photographs of him are printed in any newspaper. But north of it, equally, you get stories like that Hitler refused to take hands with him.
我一直想知道战后她发生了什么，或者在哪个时间点——是的，你不会想把那张照片放在你的Facebook主页上，对吧？那是会被“取消文化”抵制的。我们要移除那个——值得被“取消文化”抵制，那会是个问题。而且我猜，我的意思是，所以那个著名的故事是杰西·欧文斯（Jesse Owens），是的，赢得了四枚——四枚奖牌，是四枚吗？四枚奖牌，显然还有四枚奖牌？四枚奖牌。很显然他是黑人。这起到了非常大的作用……所以在梅森-迪克森线以南，没有任何一家报纸刊登他的照片。但在梅森-迪克森线以北，同样地，你会听到这样的故事：希特勒拒绝跟他握手。
Which is not true, actually. Which is not true. It's weird to be correcting a story about Hitler in order to present him in a better light, but it's not true that Hitler... I mean, Hitler did express great disapproval of Jesse Owens, no doubt about that. But he's in the Riefenstahl film.
这其实不是真的。这其实不是真的。纠正一个关于希特勒的故事以期把他表现得更好一点，这感觉有点奇怪，但希特勒没有——我的意思是，希特勒确实对杰西·欧文斯表达了极大的不满，这一点毫无疑问。但他出现在了里芬斯塔尔的电影里。
Yeah, he is. I mean, there's no attempt to censor him. No, no, no, that's right. But Hitler had been told by the organisers he would have to shake hands with... He could not pick and choose who he shook hands with. They said, basically, don't... It's not really good form for the head of state to shake hands with. So unless you're going to shake hands with literally everybody,
是的，他确实在里面。我的意思是，并没有人试图审查他。不，不，不，没错。但组织者曾告诉希特勒，他必须与……他不能挑拣他想和谁握手。他们基本上告诉他，不要……国家元首跟人握手实在不太合适。所以除非你打算跟字面意义上的每一个人握手，
you shouldn't do it at all. So he didn't really do it at all. So it's not true that he sort of blacklisted Jesse Owens. But it's kind of interesting, because if you think back to um the role played by um yeah i mean the most blatant racism in the saint louis yeah um the games yeah that this is obviously still a part of american sporting culture that will then after the war you know continue to play out yeah of
否则你根本不应该这么做。所以他基本上谁也没握。所以他把杰西·欧文斯列入黑名单并不是真的。但这挺有意思的，因为如果你回想一下，嗯，由……发挥的作用，是的，我的意思是，圣路易斯奥运会上最露骨的种族主义，是的，嗯，奥运会，是的，这显然仍然是美国体育文化的一部分，战后它将继续上演，当然，
course um so it's an american story as well as as a german story but i mean it it's the i think i mean i think the story that really sums up the role that the berlin olympics plays in this is that the um the the the the captain the officer who's in charge of the olympic village in berlin um is jewish and so three days after the end of the olympics he gets he loses his commission and he shoots himself yeah and nobody cares because by that point the eyes of the world are off are off the games um but the sense that it's been a tremendous success for germany that it's shown the reich in a kind of tremendous golden light that really does continue to to resonate out and so that's why japan puts in the bid for the games in 1940 yeah which of course never happened
嗯，所以这是一个美国的故事，同时也是一个德国的故事。但我的意思是，我认为——真正概括柏林奥运会所扮演角色的故事是，嗯，柏林奥运村的负责人、军官，嗯，是个犹太人，所以在奥运会结束三天后，他失去了军衔并开枪自杀了，是的，而且没有人关心，因为到那个时候，全世界的目光已经从奥运会上移开了。但这种感觉是：这对德国来说是一次巨大的成功，它以一种耀眼的金光展示了德意志帝国，这确实继续产生着共鸣，所以这就是为什么日本会申办1940年奥运会，是的，当然这从未发生过，
and really you're starting to see what what becomes a theme after the war that um governments start to recognize that hosting the games can really redound to your credit and it's really it's it's the 1936 games that show that and and establishes the template of course the 1940 games you know they don't go ahead they get cancelled um second world war erupts no olympic games and i realize that um essentially we have gone on for far too long we've got that this is not a sprint that this is going to be a marathon we've actually proceeded at literally half the pace that we um that we should have done so we're not going to podium with this one so perhaps perhaps we should um well perhaps we should we should uh take a break like the cuban marathon runner did have a have a an apple or an apricot or something
并且你开始看到战后成为主题的东西，那就是政府开始认识到主办奥运会确实能为你增光添彩，正是1936年的奥运会展示了这一点，并确立了这一模板。当然，1940年的奥运会并没有举办，它们被取消了，第二次世界大战爆发，没有奥运会。我意识到，嗯，本质上我们已经聊了太久了，我们发现这并不是一场短跑，而将是一场马拉松，我们目前的进展速度实际上只有我们应该达到的速度的一半左右，所以我们这次是上不了领奖台了，所以也许，也许我们应该，嗯，也许我们应该，我们应该休息一下，就像那个古巴马拉松运动员一样，吃个苹果或杏子什么的，
and do another podcast where we will go from from the end of the second world war up to the present brilliant let's do that then so we shall see you in the next podcast for well moscow los angeles london mun, you name it. Yeah, lots to do. All right, see you then. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
然后录制另一个播客，我们将在其中从二战结束一直讲到今天。太棒了，那就这么办吧。所以我们将在下期播客中见面，届时我们将讨论——莫斯科、洛杉矶、伦敦、慕尼黑，应有尽有。是的，有很多内容要讲。好了，到时候见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家分集、提前解锁、无广告收听，
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。